what's up everybody this is ross lynch
and today i'm going undercover on the
internet
[Music]
it's actually me
[Music]
twitter so this is from at chubby cookie
what did you feel when you played
jeffrey dahmer it was uncomfortable
a lot of the filming was uncomfortable
it was a really fulfilling process
i'm really happy that i did it next up
is at
gabulous lyrics ross what was your first
day as harvey kinkle like by the way
congratulations to you excited to see it
my first day as harvey kinkle was
pretty fun all the early harvey kinkle
stuff was
basically just flirting with kiernan
flirting with sabrina it's pretty fun
i had a good time next up is vicky
rojo just wondering what is your
favorite sabrina episode and which one
was the most fun
shoot love the first season your acting
is unbelievable thank you
might be my favorite role you've ever
played after jeffrey dahmer
that's nice to hear thank you i think
some of the early episodes
were really fun to watch because we did
this whole screening in
vancouver after we shot the first two
and everybody came out we went to like a
movie theater and and we all watched the
first two episodes
and as far as filming goes i think my
favorite episode of film
was when the fright club goes
to hell to get nick back i think that
was my favorite episode to film
and there was like fight scenes and
stuff it was really fun next up is
reddit
jazz sinclair and karen shipka theory is
it true that habrina
has not been endgame just because of
jason claire's jealousy
for ross lynch no no that's not
necessarily true
that's not true this is actually what
happened jazz and i were hanging out on
set
we met and quickly became the best of
friends
and the writers on the show saw that and
they decided that they wanted to write
for it because you can't really fake
chemistry
it was pretty magnetic like we couldn't
get enough of each other
as writers you have to follow what's
working
and that's what was working ross lynch
typecast
question mark how exactly would you even
describe ross lynch's type
i mean the guy played the leading man on
the disney show then played a serial
killer
yeah yeah i agree with you i guess that
was kind of on purpose
because i didn't want to be pigeonholed
or typecast now i
it's almost at a point where i was like
like what's next
i'll have to be diligent about doing
more auditions i guess
i've been slacking a little bit since
covet hit i'm not gonna lie
back to twitter at eflum chloe do you
see the cast of austin alley in team
beach one and
two double date reunion just want to
know if you guys still keep in contact
i loved austin and ali and team beach
one and two i
talked to the castmates of austin and
ally pretty frequently actually
and i just hung out with the
choreographer from team beach movie
i haven't seen anyone from the cast in a
long time but i hung out with a
choreographer
just recently he's a really good friend
of mine next up
is at danny's afterglow will you ever
paint your nails again bff they looked
really good last time
so my mom was going through a rough time
she had cancer
and when she was pregnant with me
she worked at a nail salon she named me
ross because this little kid came into
the
nail salon at the time it was like it
was almost like a sign to her
to name me ross so i painted my nails as
a uh
i guess a notion of love i i mean i
could see myself painting my nails again
i guess
sure next up at script slasher
which is kind of a sick name are you
aware that your team beach songs on
spotify you're credited as
austin moon i i can't even really
remember why that happened
but it's kind of my fault
i think it's kind of funny actually it
is what it is
this next name is hilarious it's i horny
ross
can you recommend us some new and
underrated artists
yeah there's this guy named i think his
name is jay paul
j-a-i and then um
i guess paul i-p-a-u-l he has this like
unreleased album from 2013 that's pretty
sick
diy like bedroom artist kind of sound
the parcels
are a really cool up-and-coming band
they do mostly like
funk disco sounding stuff
and the driver era check out the driver
era
next up this one's from no control heron
what's the best piece of advice you've
ever received i've received a lot of
advice
but i think the most recent one
that i've really been vibing is no one
really knows anything
okay a good way to summarize this is
before einstein came up with the theory
of relativity
a few years prior to that people were
like we discovered everything
and then einstein came around and blew
everyone's minds
so trust yourself
trust your gut if that made any sense
read books
that's my advice to you read books are
you working on something new
in the acting world there's always the
potential
like sabrina where i'll get swept up in
a week and then be in a new country
for a year but there's nothing on the
books right now i'm unemployed
next up is sassy toilet out of the box
question
would you ever consider doing theater
again
so i've done like some more like
broadway kind of stuff where it's like
mostly musicals and stuff
and i could definitely do that in the
future that i could see that happening
but if i were to do theater i would like
the idea of doing it
kind of like philip seymour hoffman
would do where it's kind of like
intense acting process kind of like the
off-broadway like
small theaters we'll see
wikipedia on march 2nd it was reported
that the driver era would be a band
consisting only of ross and rocky
for the most part that's true there's a
lot of people that help
bring everything together
but as far as the band
goes as of now it's it's me and my
brother rocky
this is from cora we don't know what
korra is but we're finding out
what is ross lynch's vocal range i'm not
actually sure
i'm like i'm like a band guy you know
like a singer songwriter but i'm not
like
classically trained so i'm not really
sure
i can sing pretty high i can sing pretty
low
why is ross lynch considered a mormon i
don't think i'm considered a mormon
my mom was raised mormon and uh
is no longer mormon every mormon that
i've met is pretty nice
but no i i don't really have a any
religious
um title i guess i'm just spiritual
does ross lynch go to school i mean i
went to school i'm 25 now i was
homeschooled most of my life
because i moved out to l.a and i started
working at a pretty young age
the disney channel was my high school
touring was my college
that's what i like to say but yes i went
to school didn't go to college
when i went to school does ross lynch
write his own songs
who writes the songs for r5 a lot of the
songs for r5
i didn't write a lot of the songs for r5
i did write
almost all the songs that are coming out
now i'm writing
for the most part i i like to be
involved in that process or else just
feels kind of phony
so i have every intention of like
creating the art
that's it for quora next up is youtube
is it just me or did ross not get the
austin alley reference with the
you made me do a double take or maybe he
didn't want to acknowledge it
i would just probably assume that
kiernan wouldn't know that reference
maybe she does i don't i don't know i
don't i don't think she would
i guess we'll never know next up is
instagram
from ann lockhart 24 would you date a
fan
your partner has to be supportive of
your dreams
so would you date a fan
yeah if you aren't a fan
of what i'm dedicating my life to i
don't know if i could date you
because that would suck okay everybody
that's it thanks so much for watching
actually me
i hope you enjoyed it now i'm signing
off the internet
have a good day